ANNOUNCER: Open content is
provided under creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation, or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu .
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: As
I've done in the previous
lectures, let me set the stage
for what we've been doing, so
we can use that to talk about
what we're going to do today.
So far, we have the following
in our language.
Right, we have assignment.
We have conditionals.
We have input/output.
And we have looping
constructs.
These are things like
FOR and WHILE loops.
And of course we've got some
data to go with that.
One of the things we said last
time was, with that set of
things, the ability to give
values-- sorry, to give names
to values-- the ability to make
decisions, the ability to
loop as a function of that, the
ability get things in and
out, we said that that actually
gave us a language we
said was Turing-complete.
And that meant, in English, that
this was enough to write
any program.
Now that's a slight lie-- or
actually in these days of
political debates, a slight
misspeaking, a wonderful
word-- it is technically
correct.
It is enough to allow us to
write any program, but it's
not enough to allow us to easily
write any program.
And so I joked, badly, I'll
agree, at the end of last
lecture, that we can just stop
now, go straight to the final
exam, because this is all
you need to know.
The point is, yes it's enough to
start with, but we want to
add things to this that let
us problem solve well.
And one of the things to think
about is, even though I've got
all of that, let's think about
what I could do, if I wanted
to write a piece of code.
Right now, you've got to
write it in one file.
It's a long sequence of
instructions, it starts at the
beginning, walks through, may
jump around a little bit, but
eventually comes down
at the end.
It's okay for the things you're
doing for the early
problem sets.
Ten lines of code.
Twenty lines of code.
Imagine instead, you're writing
code that's a hundred
thousand lines, a million
lines, of code.
You don't want to write
it in this form.
All right, and the reason you
don't want to do that is,
well, several.
First of all, it's really hard
to figure out where everything
is, where everything goes,
making sure I'm
in the right place.
To use an ancient expression
from the 1970's, which only
John and I will appreciate, it's
really hard to grok what
that code is doing, to
understand what it's trying to
make happen.
And the reason that that's the
case is, what we don't have,
are two important things.
We don't have decomposition, and
we don't have abstraction.
And that's what we're
going to add today.
So what does that mean?
Those are fancy terms.
Decomposition is a way of
putting structure
onto the code.
It's a way of breaking the
code up into modules.
Modules that makes sense
on their own.
Modules that we can reuse
in multiple places.
Modules that, if you
like, isolate
components of the process.
And abstraction is related to
that, abstraction is going to
let us suppress details.
It's going to let us bury away
the specifics of something,
and treat that computation
like a black box.
And by black box, I mean,
literally behaves like a
mysterious little black box.
You put some inputs in, it has
a contract that says if you
put the right kind of inputs
in you'll get a specific
output coming out, but you
don't have to know what's
inside of that box.
And that abstraction is
really important.
Again, imagine if I'm a writing
a piece of code.
I want to just use it, I
shouldn't have to worry about
what variables I use inside of
it, I have shouldn't have to
worry about where that is in the
code, I should be able to
just abstract it away.
And that's what we want to add
today, are those two things.
Now, our mechanism for doing
that-- or at least one
mechanism, I shouldn't say the
only one-- one mechanism for
doing that is going to be to add
functions to our language.
Now, the point of a function is
that it's going to provide
both of these things, so the
first thing it's going to do
is, it's going to let us
break up into modules.
Second thing they're going to do
is let us suppress detail.
And in essence what that does
is, the functions, and we're
going to look at a bunch of
examples in a second, these
functions are going to give us
a way to, in some or in one
way of thinking about it is
to create new primitives.
And I'm going to put those in
quotes, it's a generalization.
What do I mean by that?
The idea of a function is, that
I'm going to capture a
common pattern of computation.
Computing square root.
I'm going to capture it in a
piece of code, I'm going to be
able to refer to it by a name,
and I'm going to suppress the
details, meaning inside of that
computation, you don't
need to know what it does.
You just need to know, if I
give it the right kind of
input, it'll give me back an
input that satisfies the
contract that I set up.
And that in essence says, I've
just created the equivalent of
a new primitive.
Same way that I have
multiplication or division as
a primitive, functions are going
to give me, or somebody
else who wrote them for me as
part of a library, a new
primitive that I'm going
to be able to use.
And that gives me a lot of power
in terms of what I want
to have inside of the language.
OK.
So, let's look at an example.
To try to see what we're
going to do with this.
Before I do that though, let me
try and give you an analogy
to keep this in mind of why we
want to basically build these
abstractions and what
we need in order to
have them work together.
So here's the supposed
to say silly analogy.
You can tell my jokes
are always bad.
John's are much better, by the
way, which is why Thursday
will be a much better lay--
a better lecture.
But here's the example.
You've been hired by PBS to
produce a nice thirteen-hour
documentary, or drama,
that's going to run.
And, you know, you start by
saying, OK, thirteen hours,
I'm going to break it up into
thirteen different chunks.
I'm going to assign each chunk
to a different writer.
And they're going to go off and
write that element, that
hour's worth of stuff.
You can imagine what you get:
each hours worth of drama, if
you like, may be great, but it
may have absolutely nothing to
do with the other
twelve hours.
And unless, you know, you've
been hired to do Pirandello's
Six Characters In Search Of An
Author, this is not a great
thing, because you
get something
that is really confusing.
Now, what's the point
of the analogy?
What do I need for
those writers to
all interact together?
I need a specification.
I need a contract that says,
here's what I want in terms of
things that you're going to take
as input, to begin your
part of the drama, here's what
you're going to produce at the
output, and the details
of what they do
inside are up to them.
An idea of abstraction, that
idea of specification, is
exactly what we want to use
inside of our functions.
We won't make you write dramas
like Pirandello, but we're
going to try make you at
least write good code.
And that's we're going
to try and do.
All right.
Let's set the stage for it.
Up on the screen, I've got--
I commented it out, but I've
got a piece of code that
you've seen before,
right up here.
OK?
What is that?
It's the piece of code we wrote
for computing square
roots, square roots of actually
perfect squares.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
Just to remind you what it
does, we bound x to some
value, we set up an initial
variable called ANS or answer,
and then we run through
a little loop.
All right, we're-- well
actually, I should say that
better, we first check to see,
is x greater than or equal to
zero, if it's not, then we come
down here and we print
something out, otherwise we run
through a little loop to
get the answer, and then
we check it and we
spit something out.
It does the computation,
that's fine.
Suppose I want to compute square
roots a lot of places
in a big chunk of code.
Right now, I have to take that
piece of code and replicate it
everywhere I want in
my larger file.
And I've got to worry about,
is somebody else using ANS,
answer, as a variable, in which
case I've got to be
really careful.
Is somebody else using
x as a variable?
I've got to deal with a
lot of those details.
I want to abstract that.
And the abstraction you
see, right here.
I'm going to highlight it for
a second so you can see it.
I want you to look at it
on the handout as well.
This is the creation
of a function.
And I want to describe both the
syntax, what we're doing,
and then the semantics of
how do we use it and
what does that mean.
So.
Here's the syntax
of the function.
First of all, we have
a keyword. def.
Definition or define, depending
on which sort of
piece of history
you come from.
This is a keyword to Python that
says, when it reads this
in the file, it says, I'm
creating a definition.
I'm creating a function.
And that's follow-- so this
is, let me say this is a
keyboard-- that is followed
immediately by a name.
And this equates to that.
In this case, sqrt,
square root.
I'm saying, this is the
name I'm going to
give to this function.
This is the name to which I'm
going to refer when I want to
use this function.
All right?
And notice, immediately after
that name, we have an open and
close paren with another
variable name inside of that.
And this defines formal
parameters of this function.
Yup.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
[INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: It
does indeed, thank you.
This is me being a Scheme
hacker, not a Python hacker.
Yes, def has to be lowercase
or won't recognize it.
Thank you, John.
OK. def's the keyword.
I'm creating a function.
sqrt-- again, I'm being
careful about case-sensitive,
I'm using all lowercase here,
followed by an open paren, and
I said, formal parameters.
We'll see there could be
more than one there.
We're going to come back to what
they mean in a second,
but for now, think of them as,
or think of x, in this case,
as the place holder.
This place holder is saying, if
you give me a value for x,
inside the body of this function
I'm going to use that
value everywhere I see x.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Ah,
we're going to come back to
this in a second.
But the question was, do
I always need an input?
I can have functions with no
parameters, that's fine, I
will still need the open and
close paren there to identify
that I have no parameters.
We're going to see an
example in a second.
Good question.
Actually, I've got to get rid of
this candy, so since it was
a good question, here you go.
Nice catch.
Almost. Sorry.
OK.
No, I'm not.
I'm sorry.
I thought you had it, and then
I've got the wrong glasses on
and I realized you didn't,
so I will, ah come
back to that later.
What are we doing here?
We got definition, we got name,
we got a set of formal
parameters.
Right.
If you look at the rest of that
code, gee, it looks a lot
like what I had elsewhere.
Of what I had outside
of it, right?
It's running through a
similar set of loops.
So in some sets, as long as x
has the value I want, it ought
to do the right thing.
However, there's a couple of
other changes there that we
want to highlight.
In particular, notice-- let me
highlight it for you, if I can
find it with the wrong glasses
on-- we've got
these return commands.
So return is another keyword.
And it basically says, when you
get to this point in the
computation, stop
the computation.
Literally, return the control
from this function, and take
the value of the next
expression, and return that as
the value of the whole
computation.
Now, the one that we're most
interested in is the one
where, in fact, it gets out ANS,
so you see down here in
the code, there's a spot where
it's going to return the value
of ANS, which is what
we want, right?
That's the thing that holds the
value that we intended to
have.
But there's another couple of
places in that code where it's
got this funky-looking thing,
return none, and notice none's
in a different color.
None is a special value, and
it has the following
slightly-odd behavior: it is
a value, we can return it--
God bless-- but what none says
is, there is no value coming
back from this computation.
So when it is returned, and
we'll see this in a second, to
the interpreter, it
doesn't print.
OK.
It simply doesn't
print anything.
Nonetheless, it is actually a
value and we can use it, for
example, to do comparisons.
If we want to know, did this
function return a value or
not, rather than reserving, say,
-1 or some other special
thing which you might want to
use some other ways, it
literally returns this very
special value that says, there
is no actual value return
from this computation.
OK.
Note, by the way, if I chase
through each possible path,
like there's some IFs in here,
there's some places to go, at
least in this piece of code,
every possible path through
this code ends in a return.
And that's a good programming
discipline, to
make sure that happens.
There's an exception, which
we'll see in a second, but
I'll highlight, which is, if
we get to the end of the
procedure, there's sort of
an implicit return there.
In fact, a return of
none, in that case.
It comes out of it.
But if I look at this, right?
If I come into this code, I'm
going to check this branch
first, if it's not true, ah,
there's a return at the end of
that branch.
If it is true, I do that, and
then I've got a second test.
If it's true, I return,
otherwise a return.
So there's a return branch
on every possible
path through the code.
And that's valuable, it's
something you want to think
about as your right your own.
OK.
What do I do to use this,
in particular?
How do I invoke this?
OK, so I'm going to invoke a
function by passing in values
for the parameters.
And in this case, that literally
means typing sqrt,
with some value inside
the parens.
OK.
Now, let's just try this out
to see what happens.
I'm going to make sure I've got
it there, so if I type,
for example, sqrt
of 16, ah-ha!
What did it do?
Well, let's talk about
what it did.
What this invocation does, is
the following: it binds, and
I'm going to say this
specifically for this example,
rather than general,
it binds x to 16.
Just as you would have done with
an assignment statement
up in the top level thing.
But this binding is local.
Meaning it only holds within
the confines of the code of
this procedure.
Relative to that, think of that
as creating what we, I'm
going to call a new
environment.
Relative to that, it does all
the other execution we would
do, including, notice the first
instruction there is to
the set up a binding for ANS.
So answer, or ANS, is also
bound only locally.
Meaning, inside the
confines of this
environment of this procedure.
ANS starts off with a value of
0 and now we just run through
that loop just like
we did before.
Writing Increments it slowly,
checking to see if ANS squared
is bigger than x, and when it
gets to that point, it checks
to see, is it actually a perfect
square or not, and it
returns it.
And once it returns it, it
returns a value from that
return, that in this case
is just printed out.
All right.
Now I want to say a
couple of things
about these local bindings.
I'm going to repeat this
a second time,
because it's important.
These local bindings do not
affect any global bindings.
What does that mean?
Let me show you a little
example, and then we'll come
back to this.
I've got a little
function here.
See, I've defined f of x to be
a function that takes a value
of x in, changes x to x+1, and
then just returns the value.
OK.
So it's just adding 1 to x.
But I want you to see now what
happens if I use this.
Let's bind x to the
value of 3.
It's creating a binding for x
in this global environment.
This is what the interpreter
sees.
All right?
In fact, if I look at
x, its value is 3.
Let's bind z eh let's bind z
to the-- if I could type it
would help-- say, f of 3.
OK?
So the value is z is 4, it's
what I expect, right?
Locally x got bound to 3, I
added 1 to it, whoop-dee-doo,
I get back a 4.
But what's the value of x?
It's still 3.
The way to think of this is,
again, I've got multiple
scopes, or multiple frames, or
if we're going to come back to
those terms, I'm going to use
the word environment, because
I'm an old-time Lisp hacker,
multiple environments in which
there are bindings.
So let me spell this out in just
a little bit more detail.
What this is saying
is the following.
When I'm talking to the
interpreter, when I'm typing
things in as I just did, to that
Python environment, I'm
getting what I'm going to
call global bindings.
I'm going to draw a
little chart here.
Think of this as the, as the
world of the interpreter, in
that I've got things like x
bound to the value of 3.
When I call or invoke a
function, think of it as
creating a local table.
Inside that local table, I bind
the formal parameter,
which is what I do I did
16 right to some value.
This x only gets seen by sqrt.
Inside of there, I can bind
other things, like ANS gets
locally bound to 0, and then
it increments around and
eventually we return
that value out.
When I get to a return from
sqrt, some value is returned
back to the interpreter, and
that table goes away.
But that table does not affect
any bindings for other
instances of the variable
like x for ANS.
OK.
Let's look at a couple of
examples, just to sort of
stress that.
And one of the things I
wanted to show is, OK.
Again, I can now use a function
just as if it was a
primitive, so this is just an
assignment and I going to take
test to be the value of that, of
course nothing gets printed
because that was an assignment
statement.
All right?
So if I called sqrt alone, that
return value is done, but
in this case I bound it to
test, so I can go look at
test, and there it is.
What happens if I do that?
OK.
If you look at the code, it
printed out, it's not a
perfect square, which is what I
wanted, but now, what's the
value of test?
OK, I bound test to something,
if I look at it, it doesn't
print anything, but--
if I could type--
I can ask, is test bound to
that special name none?
The answer is yes.
Boy, this seems like
a nuance, right?
But it's a valuable thing.
It says, in each case, I return
some useful value from
this procedure.
I can check it, so if this
was part of some other
computation, I want to
know, did it find a
perfect square or not?
I don't have to go read what it
printed out in the screen.
This has returned a value
that I can use.
Because I could do a test to
say, is this a return value?
If it's not, I'll do something
else with it.
So the binding is still
there, it simply
doesn't print it out.
OK.
What do we have out of this?
Simple, seems like,
at least addition.
We've added this notion
of a function.
I've highlighted some of the key
things we got here, right?
We have that def keyword, we've
got a name, we've got a
list-- or I shouldn't say
a word list, we have a
collection of formal parameters
that we're going to
use-- we have a body, and the
body looks just like the
normal instructions we'd use,
although by the way, we ought
to be able to use functions
inside the body, which we're
going to do in a second, and
then we're going to simply
return some values
out of this.
Now I started by saying,
build these functions.
I'm trying to get both
decomposition and abstraction.
Well, you hopefully can see
the decomposition, right?
I now have a module.
OK, let me set the stage.
Imagine I wanted to do sqrt, or
square root-- no, I'm going
to use sqrt, that's the name I'm
using here-- square root a
hundred different places
in some piece of code.
Without function, I'd have to
copy that piece of code
everywhere.
Now I got one just simple
thing, and I simply have
isolated that module inside
of that function.
What about abstraction?
Well, I've got part of what
I want for abstraction.
Abstraction, again, says I'm
going to suppress details.
Now that I've written sqrt, I
can just use it anywhere I
want in the code.
You've got to rely on the fact
that I wrote it correctly, but
you can basically suppress the
details of how it's used.
There's one more piece that we'd
like to get out of that,
and that is-- you may have been
wondering, what's with
the funky stuttering here of
three double-quotes in a row.
All right?
And that is a specification.
Which is a really valuable
thing to have.
So what is the specification
going to do?
It is my place, as a programmer,
to write
information to the user.
This is me writing one hour of
that episode of Pirandello and
telling the other authors,
here's what I'm assuming as
you use it.
So it's up to me to do it right,
but if I do it, I'm
going to specify, what does
this function do?
What does it expect as input,
and any other information I
want to pass on.
And notice, by the way, if I
do that, I'm going to come
down here, and I type sqrt and
open the paren, ah-ha!
It shows me what the creator, in
this case actually I stole
this from John so what Professor
Guttag put up as his
specification for this
piece of code.
Now, it's not guaranteed
it's right, right?
You're trusting the programmer
did it right, but this now
tells you something.
What is this?
This is a wonderful piece
of abstraction.
It is saying, you don't need
to know squat about what's
inside the body of
this function.
You don't have to worry about
the parameter names, because
they're going to be preserved,
you don't need to worry about
how I'm doing it, this tells you
how you can use this, in
order to use it correctly.
Of course, I can then close
it off, and off we go.
All right, so that notion of
abstraction and I was going to
come back-- we're going to come
back to multiple times
during the term-- and it's not
just abstraction, it's the
idea of a specification.
And just to look ahead a little
bit, you could easily
imagine that I might want to
not just put a statement in
there, what the specs are,
I might want to put some
constraints.
Some specific things to check
for, to make sure that you're
calling the code right.
And it becomes a powerful way of
reasoning about the code, a
powerful way of using the code,
so those notions of
specs are really important.
Look, part of the reason I'm
flaming at you is, something
like square root, it seems dumb
to write specs on it.
Everybody knows what this
is going to do.
But you want to get into that
discipline of good hygiene,
good style.
You want to write the specs so
that everybody does in fact
know what this piece of code is
doing, and you're writing
it each time around.
OK.
Now that we've got functions,
let's see what we can do as a
problem-solving tool
using them.
In a particular, I've already
said I want to get this notion
of modularity, it's a module I
can isolate, and I want to get
the notion of abstracting away
the details, let's see how we
can actually use that to
actually write some reasonably
interesting pieces of code, but
in particular, to see how
we can use it to capture the
ideas of decomposition and
abstraction.
So I'm going to shift gears.
Start with a simple problem.
Boy, we're suddenly be
transported to Nebraska.
Or where I grew up,
Saskatchewan.
All right, we've got
a farm air problem.
I got a farmer, walks out into
his yard, one morning.
This farmer has a bunch of pigs
in a punch-- it's been a
long day-- a bunch of pigs
and a bunch of chickens.
And he walks out into the
farmyard and he observes 20
heads and 56 legs.
And for sake of argument, there
are no amputees among
the chickens and the pigs.
And the question is, so how many
pigs does he have, and
how many chickens does he have?
Wow.
What a deep problem, right?
But you're going to see
why we're going to
use this in a second.
So you know how to solve
this, this is a
fifth-grade problem, right?
And what's the way
to solve this?
System of linear equations.
What are the equations here?
Well, I could say, you know,
the number of pigs plus the
number of chickens
equals 20, right?
Because we've got 20 heads.
And then what else do I have?
Four times the number of pigs
plus two times the number of
chickens, assuming they're
not next to a
nuclear reactor, is 56.
And then how would
you solve this?
Well, it's, you sort of know
how you'd do it if this was
grammar school right?
You'd pull out your pencil and
paper, you can do it as a
matrix inversion if you know
how to do that, or you can
just simply do substitution
of one equation into
another to solve it.
That's certainly one way to do
it, but for computers that's
not necessarily the
easiest way.
So another way of solving it is
to do something we already
saw last time, which is
basically, why not simply
enumerate all possible examples
and check them?
You could say, I could have
zero chickens and 20 pigs,
does that work?
I've got one chicken and
nineteen pigs, does that work?
I've got two chickens
and eighteen
pigs, you get the idea.
So I'm going to solve this by
enumerate and check, which is
an example of what's called
a brute-force algorithm.
Meaning, I'm just going
to write a little
loop that does that.
All right, so let's go
back to our code.
That's right, let me pull
this over a little bit,
so I can see it.
And what I'd like you to look
at, I'm going to highlight it
just for a second here, is
those two pieces of code.
OK?
Let's start with solve.
OK.
Here's the idea of solve.
I'm going to have it take in as
input how many legs I got,
how many heads do I have,
and I just want to
write a little loop.
OK.
I know how to do that, right?
Write a little loop, all
I'm going to do, is
run a FOR loop here.
I'm going to let the number of
chickens be in this range.
Remember what range does, it
gives me a set or a collection
or a tuple of integers from 0
up to 1 - is the last value,
so it's going to give me
everything from 0 up to the
total number of heads.
Knowing that, I'm going to say,
OK, how many pigs are
there, well that's just how
we're, however many I had
total, minus that amount, and
then I can see, how many legs
does that give, and then I can
check, that the number of legs
that I would get for that
solution, is it even equal to
the number of legs I
started with, ah!
Interesting.
A return.
In particular, I'm going
to return a tuple.
So, a pair or collection
of those two values.
If it isn't, then I'm going to
go back around the loop, and
notice what happens.
If I get all the way around the
loop, that is, all the way
through that FOR loop and I
never find a path that takes
me through here, then the last
thing I'm going to do is
return a pair or a tuple
with a special
simple number none twice.
Yep.
Are you telling me I want
parens there and
not, and not braces?
All right.
I hate this language, because I
always want to have parens.
Every time you see a square
bracket, put a paren in.
All right?
Thank you, Christy.
I'll get it eventually .
Having done that, right,
notice what I've got.
First of all, two parameters.
It's OK.
All it says is, when I call
this, I need to pass in two
parameters for this to work.
All right?
Now, if I want to use that,
I'm going to use a second
piece of code here,
called Barnyard.
I'm going to read in a couple
of values, convert them into
integers, and then I'm
going to use solve to
get a solution out.
And what do I know
about solve?
It is going to give me back a
tuple a collection of two
things, and so check
out the syntax.
I can give two names, which
will get bound to the two
parts of that return tuple.
OK, pigs will be the first part,
chickens will be the
second part.
OK, and then once I've got that,
well, notice: I can then
check to see, did I return
that special symbol none?
Is the first part.
That says, I took the branch
through here that eventually
got to the end and said, there
wasn't a solution, in which
case I'm
going to print out, there ain't
no solution, otherwise
I'll print out the pieces.
All right, let's check it out.
Ah, what did I say?
Twenty and 56, Right?
OK, notice the form.
I've got two parameters, they're
separated by a comma.
Ah, right.
Sorry?
Yeah, but I see-- it's legs and
heads, but it should not
still have--
Oh, sorry.
Thank you.
I've been doing the
wrong thing.
I want Barnyard this way, and if
I had looked when I opened
the paren, it would have shown
me a closed paren with no
parameters.
Aren't you glad I make mistakes,
so you can see how
well I can fix from these?
All right.
Now I call that, and it says,
tell me how many heads you
want, give it a 20, and tell
it how many legs you want,
give it 56, and it prints
out the answers.
I know, whoop-dee-doo.
But notice what's
inside if here.
First of all, notice
the modularity.
I've used solve.
All right?
Right there.
I've captured it as
a computation.
It's buried away, all the
details are suppressed.
I can use that to return values,
which I can then use
elsewhere, which I did-- and
if I just come back and
highlight this-- inside
of that computation.
But I don't have to know, inside
of Barnyard, what the
values are used inside
of solve.
I don't know what the names of
the variables are, I don't
care, I can basically suppress
away that detail.
Second thing we saw is, that
using this as a computation, I
can return multiple values.
Which is actually of
real value to me
here as I use that.
OK.
Yeah.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Ah.
The question was, when it
returns, how does it
distinguish between local
and other things?
So let me try and answer that.
Inside of solve, solve creates
an environment where inside of
that, it has bindings for the
parameters it's going to use.
All right?
Like, number of-- wait, what
did we call a were solve--
number of legs and
number of heads.
OK, those are bound locally.
When solve is done, it wraps up,
if you like, a value that
it returns.
Which is that.
That expression, or that
value, or that value,
literally gets passed back out
of that local environment to
the value that comes
back out of it.
So in particular, what's solved
returns is a pair.
It could be the pair of none,
none, it could be the pair of,
you know, whatever the answer
was that we put up there.
That value comes back out and
is now available inside the
scope of Barnyard.
OK.
And Barnyard then uses that.
Question?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Here?
So the question is, why is this
return on the same level
as the FOR?
Why do you think?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: No.
Good question.
All right?
So what's going to
happen here?
If I'm inside this FOR, OK, and
I'm running around, if I
ever hit a place where this
test is true, I'm going to
execute that return,
that return returns
from the entire procedure.
OK?
So the return comes back
from the procedure.
So the question was, why is
this return down at this
level, it says, well if I ever
execute out of this FOR loop,
I get to the end of the FOR
loop without hitting that
branch that took me through the
return, then and only then
do I want to actually say,
gee, I got to this place,
there isn't any value to return,
I'm going to return
none and none.
I'm still trying to get rid
of this candy, Halloween's
coming, where were we?
There's one, thank you.
I don't think I'm going
to make it, I did.
Thank you.
Make sense?
The answer is no, I want parens
to create tuple and I
get really confused about
the difference
between lists and tuples.
For now, the code is working.
Yes is the answer, all right?
And we're having a difference
of opinion as to whether we
should use a tuple or
a list here, right?
But the answer is
yes, you can.
And my real answer is, go try it
out, because obviously you
can tell I frequently do this
the wrong way and the TAs give
me a hard time every time.
John.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG:
Is the microphone on?
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Yes.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: As you'll
see next week, tuples
and lists are very close
to the same thing.
In almost any place where you
can get away with using tuples
you can use lists.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Yes.
PROFESSOR JOHN GUTTAG: But
want to emphasize word is
almost, because we'll see a
couple of places where if it
expects a tuple and you
use a list you'll
get an error message.
But we'll see all
that next week.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Right,
when the real pro comes in to
pick up the pieces I'm leaving
behind for him.
OK.
Let me pull this back up.
What we're doing now is we're
building this encapsulation.
Now one of the things you notice
here by the way is, you
know, this in essence just
solves the simple problems.
Suppose I now add one
other piece to this.
The farmer is not keeping a
great set of things so in
addition to pigs, and chickens
he raises spiders.
I have no idea why.
He's making silk I guess.
Right?
Why am I giving you
this example?
I want to show you how easy
it is to change the code.
But, notice, once I've
added this I
actually have a problem.
This is now an under-constrained
problem.
I have more unknowns than
I have equations.
So you know from algebra I can't
actually solve this.
There may be multiple
solutions to this.
What would I have to do
to change my code?
And the answer is fortunately
not a lot.
So I'm going to ask you to
look now at this set of
things, which is solve
1 and Barnyard 1.
OK.
The change is, well, on Barnyard
1 it looks much the
same as it did for Barnyard.
Right, I'm going to read in the
values of the number of
heads and the number of legs.
I'm going to use solve 1 as
before, but now I'm going to
bind out three variables.
And then I'm going to do
a similar thing to
print things out.
But would the solver do?
Well here what I'd like
to do is to run
through a couple of loops.
Right, how would I solve
this problem?
You can use the same enumerate
and check idea, but now say
gee let me pick how many
pigs there are.
Is that the one I used first?
Sorry, let me pick the number
of spiders there are.
Having chosen the number of
spiders, let me pick how many
chickens I have. With those two
in place, I now know how
many pigs I must have
and I can run
through the same solution.
The reason I'm showing you this
is this is another very
standard structure.
I now have two nested loops.
One running through a choice for
one parameter, another one
running through a choice
for a second parameter.
And then the rest
of the solution
looks much like before.
I'm going to get the total
number of legs out.
I'm going to check to see
if it's right or not.
And again I'm going to return
either a three tuple there or
a three tuple there.
It's part of what I want,
because I'm going to bind
those values out.
And if I run that example,
Barnyard 1, I don't know we'll
give it 20 heads, 56 legs;
and it find a solution.
I ought to be able to
run something else.
I don't know, give
me some numbers.
How many heads?
Pick an integer, somebody.
STUDENT: 5.
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: 5.
All right.
How many legs?
10?
All right.
We got an easy one.
Let's just for the
heck of it --
I should have found some
better examples
before I tried this.
No mutant spiders here.
OK, so what have I done?
I just added a little
bit more now.
I'm now running through
a pair of loops.
Again notice the encapsulation,
that nice
abstraction going on, which
is what I want.
Once I get to this stage though
by the way, there might
be more than one solution.
Because in an under-constrained
problem
there could be multiple
solutions.
So suppose I want to capture
all of them or
print all of them out.
Well I ought to be able
to do that by simply
generalizing the loop.
And that's what the next
piece of code on your a
hand out shows you.
I'm just going to let
you look at this.
If you look at solve 2, it's
going to run through the same
kind of loop, printing out
all of the answers.
But it's going to keep going.
In other words it doesn't just
return when it finds one, it's
going to run through
all of them.
All right?
Sounds like a reasonable
thing to do.
Notice one last piece.
If I'm going to do that, run
through all possible answers,
I still want to know,
gee, what if
there aren't any answers?
How do I return that case?
And that shows you one other
nice little thing we want to
do, which is if I look in this
code notice I set up a
variable up here called Solution
Found, initially
bound to false.
The rest of that code's
a pair of loops.
Pick the number of spiders.
Pick the number of chickens.
That sets up the
number of pigs.
Figure out the legs.
See if it's right.
If it is right, I'm going to
print out the information but
I'm also going to change
that variable to true.
And that allows me then, at the
end of that pair of loops
when I get down to this point
right here, I can check to see
did I find any solution and if
not in that case print out
there is no solution.
So this gives you another nice
piece which is I can now look
for first solution, I can look
for all solutions, and I can
maintain some internal variables
that let me know
what I found.
A trick that you're going to
use a lot as you write your
own functions.
All right, I want to end up with
the last 10 minutes with
a different variation on how
to use functions to think
about problems. And that is to
introduce the idea of recursion.
How many of you have heard
the term used before?
How may have you heard the term
used before in terms of
programming languages?
Great.
For the rest you,
don't sweat it.
This is a highfalutin term that
computer scientists use
to try and make them look like
they're smarter than they
really are.
But it is a very handy way of
thinking about, not just how
to program, but how to
break problems down
into nice sized chunks.
And the idea behind recursion
I'm going to describe with a
simple example.
And then I'm going to show you
how we can actually use it.
The idea of recursion is that
I'm going to take a problem
and break it down into a simpler
version of the same
problem plus some steps
that I can execute.
I'm go to show you an example
of a procedure, sorry a
function, in a second.
But let me give you actually
an analogy.
If you look at US law, and you
look at the definition of the
US legal code that defines
the notion of a
natural born US citizen.
It's actually a wonderful
recursive definition.
So what's the definition?
If you're born in the United
States you are by definition a
natural born US citizen.
We call that a base case.
It's basically the
simplest possible
solution to the problem.
Now if you were not born in
the United States, you may
still be, under definition, a
natural born US citizen if
you're born outside this United
States, both of your
parents are citizens of the
United States and at least one
parent has lived in
the United States.
There's a wonderful
legal expression.
But notice what that is.
It's a recursive definition.
How do you know that your
parents, at least one of your
parents satisfies
the definition?
Well I've reduced the problem
from am I a natural born US
citizen to is one
of my parents a
natural born US citizen?
And that may generalize again
and it keeps going until you
either get back to Adam
and Eve, I guess.
I don't think they were born in
the US as far as I know, or
you find somebody who satisfies
that definition or
you find that none
of your parents
actually are in that category.
But that second one is called
the inductive step, or the
recursive step.
And in my words it says break
the problem into a simpler
version of the same problem
and some other steps.
And I think this is best
illustrated by giving you a
simple little piece of code.
I use simple advisedly here.
This is actually a piece of code
that is really easy to
think about recursively and is
much more difficult to think
about in other ways.
And the piece of code is suppose
I have a spring and I
want to know if it's
a palindrome.
Does it read the same
thing left to
right as right to left.
OK?
How would I solve that?
If the string has no elements
in it it is obviously a
palindrome.
If the string has one element
in it, it's a palindrome.
There's the base case.
If it's longer than one,
what do I want to do?
Well I'd like to check the two
end points to see are they the
same character?
And if they are, then oh,
I just need to know is
everything else in the
middle a palindrome?
I know it sounds simple, but
notice what I just did.
I just used a recursive
definition.
I just reduced it to a smaller
version of the same problem.
That is if I can write code that
would solve all instances
of smaller size strings, then
what I just described will
solve the larger size one.
And in fact that's exactly what
I have. I would like you
to look at this piece of
code right here called
isPalindrome.
Notice what it says.
I'm going to pass in a string,
call it s, binds it locally,
and it says the following.
It says if this is a string of
length 0 or 1, I'm done.
I'm going to return
the answer true.
Otherwise I'm going to check to
see is the first and last,
there's that - 1 indexing, is
the first and last element of
the string the same?
And if that's true is everything
in the string,
starting at the first element
and removing the last element,
a palindrome?
Let me remind you.
By saying first element remember
we start at 0 as the
initial indexing point.
Wonderful recursive
definition.
OK, let's try it out.
Go back over here and we're
going to say isPalindrome.
How did I actually spell this?
Palindrome with a capital P.
Only in New York, in Canada we
pronounce it Palindrome.
When you're teaching it you get
to call it your way, I'm
going to call it my way.
Sorry John, you're
absolutely right.
OK.
Notice by the way, there's
that nice speck going on
saying put a string here.
It's going to return true if
it's a PAIL-indrome and false
if it's a PAL-indrome.
And it says true.
Now maybe you're
bugged by this.
I know you're bugged by my
bad humor, but too bad.
Maybe you're bugged by this,
saying wait a minute, how does
this thing stop?
This is the kind of definition
that your high school geometry
teacher would have rapped
your knuckles over.
You can't define things in
terms of themselves.
This is an inductive
definition.
Actually we could prove
inductively that it holds, but
how do we know it stops?
Well notice what the computation
is doing. it's
looking first to see am I in the
base case, which I'm done.
If I'm not I'm just going to
reduce this to a smaller
computation.
And as long as that smaller
computation reduces to another
smaller computation, eventually
I ought to get to
the place where I'm down
in that base case.
And to see that I've written
another version of this, which
I'm going to use here, where I'm
going to give it a little
indentation.
I'm going to call this
palindrome 1.
Sorry about that.
Palindrome 1.
I'm going to give it a
little indentation so
that we can see this.
OK.
Code is right here.
And all it's doing is when I'm
getting into the different
places I'm simply printing out
information about where I am.
What I want you to see is notice
what happened here.
OK.
I'm calling palindrome
with that.
It first calls it
on that problem.
And the code over here says,
OK gee, if I'm in the base
case do something.
I'm not, so come down here check
that the two end points
a and a are the same and
call this again also.
Notice what happens.
There's this nice unwrapping
of the problem.
I just doubled the indentation
each time so you can see it.
So each successive call, notice
what's happening.
The argument is getting
reduced.
And we're going another
level in.
When we get down to this point,
we're calling it with
just a string of length one.
At that point we're in the base
case and we can unwrap
this computation.
We say, ah, that's now true.
So I can return true here.
Given that that's true and I
already checked the two end
points, that's true,
that's true.
And I unwrap the computation
to get back.
You are going to have to
go play with this.
Rock it if you like to try
and see where it goes.
But I want to stress again, as
long as I do the base case
right and my inductive or
recursive step reduces it to a
smaller version of the same
problem, the code will in fact
converge and give me
out an answer.
All right, I want to show you
one last example of using
recursion because we're going
to come back to this.
This is a classic example
of using recursion.
And that is dating from
the 1200s and
it is due to Fibonacci.
Does anyone know the history
of what Fibonacci
was trying to do?
Sorry, let me re-ask that.
Fibonacci.
Which actually is son of Bonacci
which is the name of
his father who was apparently
a very friendly guy.
First of all, does anyone know
what a Fibonacci number is?
Wow.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON: Right,
we're going to do that in a
second, but the answer is
Fibonacci numbers, we define
the first two.
Which are both defined to be,
or I can define them in
multiple ways, 0 and 1.
And then the next Fibonacci
number is the sum of the
previous two.
And the next number is the
sum of the previous two.
Do you know the history
of this?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR ERIC GRIMSON:
Exactly.
Thank you.
Bad throw, I'm playing
for the Yankees.
Sorry John.
The answer is Fibonacci actually
was actually trying
to count rabbits back
in the 1200s.
The idea was that rabbits could
mate after a month, at
age one month.
And so he said, if you start off
with a male and a female,
at the end of one month they
have an offspring.
Let's assume they have
two offspring.
At the end of the next month
let's assume those offspring
have offspring.
Again a male and female.
The question was how many
rabbits do you have at
the end of a year?
At the end of two years?
At the end of more than that
number of years, and so.
We can do this with the
following level definition.
We're going to let pairs of 0,
the number of pairs at month
0, actually it would not
be 0 it would be 1.
We let the number of pairs
at month 1 be 1.
And then the number of pairs
at month n is the number of
pairs at month n - 1 plus
the number of pairs
at month n - 2.
The sum of the previous two.
If I write Fibonacci, you
see it right there.
And the reason I want to show
you this is to notice that the
recursion can be doubled.
So this says, given a value x,
if it's either 0 or 1, either
of those two cases,
just return 1.
Otherwise break this down
into two versions
of a simpler problem.
Fib of x - 1 and fib of x - 2,
and then take the sum of those
and return that as the value.
Notice if I'm going to have two
different sub problems I
need to have two base cases
here to catch this.
And if I only had one
it would error out.
And as a consequence, I can go
off and ask about rabbits.
Let's see.
At the end of 12 months,
not so bad.
At the end of two years, we're
not looking so good.
At the end of three years,
we are now in Australia.
Overrun with rabbits.
In fact I don't think the thing
ever comes back, so I'm
going to stop it because it
really gets hung up here.
And I'm going to restart it.
What's the point of this?
Again, now that I can think
about things recursively, I
can similarly break things down
into simpler versions of
the same problem.
It could be one version.
It could be multiple versions.
And we're going to come back
throughout the term to think
about how to code programs
that reflect this.
The last point I want to make
to you is, you've started
writing programs that you
would think of as being
inherently iterative.
They're running through
a loop.
It's a common way of thinking
about problems. Some problems
are naturally tackled
that way.
There are other problems that
are much more naturally
thought of in a recursive
fashion.
And I would suggest palindrome
as a great example of that.
That's easy to think
about recursively.
It's much harder to think
about iteratively.
And you want to get into the
habit of deciding which is the
right one for you to use.
And with that, we'll
see you next time.